far east within the ancient kingdom of
ET lie the five forts the five forts
each are large enough to house 10,000
men and their massive walls stand nearly
a thousand feet high the five forts in
ET are still used to this day to guard
the golden Empire for graders out of the
gray wastes which lies beyond the five
forts lie between the bleeding sea and
the mountains of the morn they
effectively block anything from entering
iki from the further east
no one knows what lies beyond the gray
waste and the fort's are said to give
off an aura of something godlike or
demonic seemingly as though there is
ancient power behind them they are made
entirely of smooth black stone that is
still to this day unmarked by time the
bloodstone Emperor of UT was said to
have cast aside his true gods to worship
a black stone that had fallen from the
sky he practiced dark magic necromancy
torture and feasted on the flesh of
humans he was said to have taken a tiger
woman for his bride many scholars
believe that bloodstone was the first
high priest of the Sinister Church of
the starry wisdom which according to the
world of Ice and Fire
still persists to this day the black
stone as well as the starry wisdom are
direct references to Lovecraftian lore
in H P Lovecraft's Cthulhu Mythos the
Church of the starry wisdom is a cult
that worships NAR latet the hunter of
the dark Marten references Lovecraft a
lot and A Song of Ice and Fire there's
too much to discuss here so this will be
the topic of future videos bloodstone
may mirror the night's king the 13th
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch who
took a corpse woman to bride and made
blood sacrifices to strange gods in the
annals of the firt East it is said that
it was blood stones betrayal of his
sister whom he had usurped to become
Emperor and the terror that he unleashed
upon his people that led to the long
night they speak in the east of a hero
who will did the flaming sword called
light bringer so that light and love
could return yet again but according to
the people of the Far East and ye T the
world has been a broken place since then
the way the five forts which block off
eet n effectively the rest of Essos from
the frozen desert known only as the gray
waste is extraordinarily similar to the
way the ice wall in the north of
Westeros lost the Seven Kingdoms off
from the land of always winter and the
Haunted Forest beyond the five ports are
even said to have been raised to keep
the Lion of night and his demons from
the realms of men just like the legends
of the wall claim that it was built to
keep the others from the realms of men
both esos and Westeros have giant
barriers in place to guard off some
threat a threat which apparently made
its initial appearance during the long
night and affected both sides of the
world but how is that possible the
others came out of the north of Westeros
far from within the land of always
winter that's on the other side of the
world
east of eeet is the frozen gray waste
and then well we don't know we haven't
seen the rest of a map assuming that the
planet is round there has to be a place
where the two sides meet what if the
gray waste of Essos and the far north of
Westeros are connected and when the long
knife happened the others invaded not
only Westeros but esos as well this
would explain why the stories of the
long night and the last hero extend far
beyond Westeros in every part of the
world there are tales of the warrior
that led men to victory high Kroon the
hero Nefarian azor Ahai Yente our
eldritch shadow chaser all are different
names for the hero who fought the
darkness if the others did attack from
both directions then it seems as though
there would have had to have been more
than one hero perhaps one in Westeros
and one in Essos through time the
legends made them one one hero of many
names that fought for the dawn in
Westeros it was the children who helped
men built the great wall of ice to keep
the others out but who erected the five
forts the oily black stone that they are
made of appears throughout all of
Westeros and Essos the sea stone share
the idol of Toad Isle the mazes of Laura
always unexplained always of unknown
origin the biggest hints that we have
relate to the sea so chair of the Iron
Islands and the item toad Isle the
drowned odd is worshipped on the Iron
Islands this religion seems to be
heavily inspired by H P Lovecraft's
Cthulhu Mythos that is not dead which
can eternal lie and with strange Aeons
even death may die
HP Lovecraft the Call of Cthulhu what is
dead may never die but rises again
harder and stronger george RR martin a
Song of Ice and Fire
upon closer inspection of their history
yet another reference to Lovecraft can
be found may soothe Arianna the Iron
Islands wrote in his manuscript that the
sea stone chair was created by a race of
half fish half humans known as the deep
ones
these creatures are directly borrowed
from Lovecraftian mythology in the
Cthulhu Mythos they are a sea dwelling
part man part fish creature with webbed
hands and webbed feet they are
worshippers of the god Cthulhu and they
also have a fondness for mating with
humans on the island of toads the
worshipers of the toad Idol are thought
to be descended from those who carved it
they are said to have an unpleasant
fish-like appearance to their face and
many have webbed feet and webbed hands
is it possible that the people of Toad
Isle are truly descended from the deep
ones bleeding sea lies north of the five
forts and the mountains of the mourn and
the shadow lands further south together
they form a barrier that separates the
gray waste from the rest of Essos could
the bleeding see me the dwelling place
of the Deep Ones or at least one of
their dwelling places the black stone
appears throughout all the world which
makes sense because the deep ones are
intelligent water dwelling beings they
simply could swim to a different part of
the world and disappear without a trace
beneath the sea
was it the deep ones that built the five
forts and do they still lurk within the
bleeding sea to this day with all of our
attention focused on the north of
Westeros we've forgotten about the Far
East which just as little is known of if
the others came both wait last time why
would they not again perhaps the deep
ones knew they may come again so they
helped build the forts to guard the
realm there has to be a savior in Essos
and there has to be a savior in Westeros
Danny seems to be the best candidate for
esos and quite tells her that to go west
you must go east this makes perfect
sense if they connect on the other side
as for Westeros bran seems like the most
likely candidate in my opinion whoever
the heroes are
it is now clear to me that the same
story played out on both Essos and
Westeros thousands of years ago the long
night came the last hero saved the world
and a barrier was erected with the help
of non-human beings these parallels when
examined seemed to suggest that we must
not only look north when the winter
comes
but east as well thank you guys for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more ideas of Ice and Fire